we got that scooter maybe it's not what
are you doing
we're gonna all right I'm not feeling
down we're gonna do a big dumb crazy
thing you'll see all right we're gonna
see you can make three laps around these
cans five laps around
all right
the Jack asked practice lap footage and
taking it outside there's two of these
they're just pouring into the grass all
right we'll use this empty bottle here
is this MDL yeah
yes I'm coming right now in first
position walk owner yes
three
Oh ticked it
we need to get a wheelchair Oh
don't knock over the bottle left
this is the dumbest thing ever laughs
8.0
I could still apparently I could still
film like the whole cast of animations
arguing
okay this is a ghetto super lame
scoreboard three two one
now
one is searched don't run over my foot
nine
pick up the pace man
you're getting slower and that fork
all right brother fishier did you all
right maggot or ghetto scoreboard focus
all right seven point three two one
but
8.6 so far
I'll bring it back you get going
laughs
Oh
but
7.5 you're in close
laughs 7.0 all right you're too nice for
lunch guys and wings these are all mine
no one else gets any five laps no
bottles all right we're starting over
oh come on now you gotta try that new
ghetto scoreboard sorry yeah it's I'm
filming let's go
who's got the timer ready all right
focus no bottles broke you know it
doesn't count no balls they bumped to
one
laughs
9.3
left 7.8
laughs 7.9
that's 8.4 Italian last laugh
okay kiddo scoreboard all right save
your DMF because he's a douche which is
me I thought all right drew you got
seven point three seven point four drew
you are the winner
I offered from me and Gerald storage
from that guy I can't really accept the
graciously but I appreciate you know I'm
gonna draw you a little gold medal here
I just
victorious music immunity
you